[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce qu'ils mag
nous sommes au ski cube et nous allons
parler création d'entreprise avec notre
invité alexandra rosetti bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes maire de
voisins-le-bretonneux et vice-présidente
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines délégué au
développement économique et à
l'attractivité du territoire vous êtes
également conseillère départementale et
ma première question est la suivante
pourquoi est-ce que 50 ans nevin a fait
ce choix de développer cette politique
d'accompagnement à la création d
entreprise parce que pour saint quentin
en yvelines le développement économique
est une vraie priorité puisque le
développement économique et bien c'est
le marqueur de la richesse et dynamisme
d'un territoire et donc la création
d'entreprise mais c'est aussi une façon
de créer de l'emploi et ce qui nous
tient surtout à coeur est bien c'est que
les gens aient plaisir à vivre et à
travailler sur notre territoire et bien
je vous propose tout de suite un petit
point en images sur notamment le
dispositif
l'entrepreneuriat pour tous
en moyenne par an ce qui cube reçoit
plus de 1200 personnes qui ont un projet
de création d'entreprise qu'on
accompagne sur son sur leur projet et on
a environ à peu près 25 à 30% de
création d'entreprise effective
[Musique]
je suis arrivé avec une idée mais qui
est pas figée qui était en pleine
évolution et ce parcours-là
d'entrepreneuriat pour tous m'a permis
de la fim et de pouvoir me poser les
bonnes questions et ne pas être tout
seul face à toutes les interrogations on
accompagne tous types d'entreprises donc
ça peut être des porteurs de projets
solos qui vont se lancer en micro
entreprise comme des sociétés à plus de
plus grande taille il y à des formations
et d'accompagnement individuel sur la
partie individuelle on a de
l'accompagnement classique au montage du
bus ce qu'on appelle du business plan
donc ça va de l'étude de marché à la
partie financière aux aspects juridiques
et on nous avons en parallèle également
des formations et des ateliers dont axoa
collectif dans lequel on fait des
ateliers thématiques qui aborde les
différents sujets de la création
d'entreprise ça prend cinq minutes à
créer mais prend entreprise sur internet
et tout ce que ça implique en amont et
en aval c'est colossal c'est vraiment un
métier par jour à maîtriser à
appréhender ça a vraiment été un plus
dans le sens où si ç'avait été payant ma
situation j'étais demandeur d'emploi ça
aurait été un frein de me dire que
j'aurais dû en effet financer ça donc
c'est un réel plus sachez qu'un porteur
de projet qui a été accompagné pour son
projet de création d'entreprise à 30% de
chances de plus de réussite à 3 ans
qu'une entreprise qui n'aura pas été
accompagnée
nous sommes toujours aux quais cube avec
alexandra rosetti l'entrepreneuriat pour
tous a totalisé pour cette première
édition 60 candidats parmi lesquels 14
ont été retenus est-ce que ce dispositif
est voué à se pérenniser alors oui parce
qu'au vu des bons retours qu'on a
justement sur cette première promotion
nous avons déjà lancé un deuxième appel
à candidatures et donc nous sommes en
train d'examiner justement qui sera
retenu pour la deuxième promotion de
l'entrepreneuriat pour tous est ce que
d'autres dispositifs ont été mis en
place alors déjà ici à la maison de
l'entreprise qui porte bien son nom
quelqu'un qui veut créer son entreprise
peut venir et être accompagnés avoir des
conseils sur comment faire une étude de
marché comment vous travaillez sur son
plan de financement donc déjà ici nous
avons des conseillers soit déconseillé
de saint-quentin meilleurs soient des
partenaires comme vge qui peuvent
répondre à toutes ces questions et puis
nous avons également lancé cette année
le bus de la création donc toujours avec
notre partenaire bg&e qui a commencé à
aller un petit peu dans différents
quartiers de saint quentin pour
rencontrer des potentiels créateurs
d'entreprise qui n'auraient pas l'idée
de venir jusqu'ici et puis l'idée c'est
aussi d'aller dans toutes les communes
t-il de souhaiterait pour justement
l'air à la rencontre des créateurs et
puis d'habitude nous faisons également
une semaine de la création
au mois de juin est là cette année on a
un petit peu repoussé puisque nous
allons avoir la chance d'accueillir le
big tour avec la bpi france donc le 20
septembre qui est un événement vraiment
très important puisqu'il fait le tour de
la france il va terminer à 5 ans pas
pour venir justement à la rencontre des
demandeurs d'emploi avec différents
dispositifs et donc nous allons inscrire
notre nos actions de création
d'entreprises dans cette dans cet
événement et le financement dans tout ça
par exemple si j'ai une super idée
d'entreprise comment est ce que je me
prends concrètement alors d'abord vous
venez ici pour être justement conseiller
accompagner et donc si vous avez besoin
par exemple de fonds propres et bien
vous pouvez peut-être prétendre un prêt
d'honneur à taux zéro ce sont des prêts
qui sont instruits par initiative ski
qui est donc un partenaire très
important pour nous et si l'initiative
estiment que vous pouvez avoir ce prêt
est bien se fera ensuite effet levier
auprès des banques pour obtenir des
prêts pour votre entreprise et bien
justement je vous propose de regarder en
détail initiative qui
j'ai obtenu auprès de ski nice y at il
un prêt d'honneur donc après sur ma
personne à hauteur de 35 mille euros à
0% remboursables en trois ans ça m'a
permis de recruter mon premier salarié
qui aujourd'hui fait partie de l'équipe
partout
l'initiative saint quentin en yvelines
est une association qui regroupe des
acteurs économiques de l'ensemble du
bassin d'activités de saint quentin en
yvelines mais également au delà des
yvelines et l'agglomération en tant que
tel et administrateur de cette
association et les fonds qu'apporte
l'ensemble des membres sont des fonds
publics privés associatifs
donc c'est tout un process partenariale
qui permet aux entreprises d'obtenir des
financements de bonnes conditions aux
propos des prêtres qui commence à 5000
euros et qui vont jusqu'à 100000 euros
5000 euros pour un projet de création
lorsqu'il s'agit d'une activité très
résidentiel mais la moyenne des prêts
qu'on propose aujourd'hui avoisiner 20 à
25 mille euros pour y accéder il faut
être créateur ou dirigeants
d'entreprises à 50 ans nîmes les projets
qui sont financés sont des projets de
création de développement de reprise des
projets liés à l'innovation aux finances
beaucoup beaucoup de startups aller
chercher l'argent offert le lever de
fonds c'est pas quelque chose de simple
surtout dans une phase de démarrage de
projets vous partez d'un produit qui se
prépare vous allez développer le projet
vous trouvez un marché vous allez
vérifier
l'attractivité de votre solution vous
allez devoir la mettre au point tout ça
c'est des phases qui intéresse peu je
veux dire les investisseurs et sur
lequel on cherche plutôt des moyens qui
sont localisés qui vont nous permettre
d'amener une forme de preuve qui est
souvent ce qui est attendu par les
investisseurs mais notre souhait aussi
c'est de proposer un effet levier c'est
une partie du puzzle financier la
plupart du temps en tout cas cette
première pièce est capital parce qu'elle
permet d'avoir accès à des financements
pour exemple les banques qui participent
à notre comité de sélection des projets
attendent souvent la décision
d'initiative 50 ans du bim pourrait même
s'engager à posteriori
[Musique]
alexandra rosetti initiative qui ça
signifie également présenté son projet
devant un jury professionnel si on peut
dire que c'est une forme de test bah oui
parce que on peut avoir une idée mais
n'est pas forcément viable donc c'est
vrai que dans le passé devant des
experts un petit peu en la matière ça
permet de tester et voir si c'est une
une idée qui est intéressante ou ou non
sur le long terme et vous en tant qu'élu
de terrain est-ce que vous avez des
retours justement des entrepreneurs
alors oui parce que justement j'ai à
coeur maintenant d'aller dans les
entreprises que l'on a aidé au travers
de ce prêt pour voir un petit peu si ça
les a aidés et les retours que j'ai
aujourd'hui je suis allé c'était une
entreprise de cyber sécurité il y en a
une autre plutôt sur la reprographie par
exemple bon bah on a vraiment de très
bons retours parce que ça les a vraiment
aidés et surtout à passer aussi la crise
là convient de qu'on vient de vivre et
alors vous à titre personnel pourquoi
vous avez choisi de vous investir sur
ces sujets là en particulier alors c'est
parce que dans le mandat précédent j'ai
été délégué à l'habitat j'ai également
été délégué à l'aménagement ce qui me
donne une vision assez complète du
territoire et du coup je peux pour moi
c'était intéressant voilà de passer au
développement économique c'est vraiment
un
un aspect prioritaire pour saint quentin
comme si tout est lié c'est aussi
l'immobilier d'entreprise qui est lié à
cette délégation donc voilà donc c'était
une façon de compléter ma vue de ma
connaissance de saint quentin en
yvelines dans son ensemble alors est ce
que les entrepreneurs les nouveaux
entrepreneurs qui ont des bonnes idées
de nouvelles idées viennent s'installer
ici spécifiquement saint quentin en
yvelines
oui alors ils viennent dans notre
incubateur ski tube donc qui
accueille des start up innovantes le 6 à
24 mois à peu près et qui sont
accompagnés alors il arrive avec une
idée de départ ils sont sélectionnés par
un jury mais également qu'ils vérifient
que l'idée a du potentiel et puis
ensuite ils sont accompagnés pendant
deux ans pour arriver à essayer de créer
leur entreprise à la fin nous allons
justement découvrir un petit focus sur
l'incubateur de saint quentin en
yvelines
[Musique]
et
or si car c'est une marketplace
d'autopartage pour le transport du
cheval ça s'inscrit complètement dans
l'air du temps d'un point de vue
numérique et 50 ans et vit non seulement
c'est très dynamique mais en plus c'est
un énorme vivier et l'incubateur est
vraiment
nous ici on a un incubateur généralistes
c'est à dire qu'on accompagne tous types
de projets quel que soit on va dire son
secteur d'activité donc on a une très
grande variété projet ça va de
l'agriculture 2.0 est la e-santé à la
silver economy la start-up ici va
pouvoir bénéficier les relations qu'on
peut avoir avec les crampons pour les
pme que ce soit pour mettre au point un
produit que ce soit pour expérimenter un
produit en incubation on peut postuler
quel que soit en matière de prêt de
maturité son projet on peut avoir des
projets qui sont relativement en face à
mons d'ailleurs on a une idée on a une
bonne connaissance du marché mais voilà
il ya encore beaucoup de chemin à
parcourir et l'accélération ça s'adresse
à des start-up ont déjà non une preuve
de marché c'est à dire qu'elles ont déjà
des clients ont déjà le chiffre
d'affaires est en phase de croissance
accélère et on est là pour les
accompagner sur ce qu'ils sont de lever
tronic du recrutement se médiatiser et
organiser la structure par exemple là en
ce moment j'ai 40 heures de travail avec
un avocat qui est fournie par cet
incubateur et ça me permet de revoir
tous les contrats de revoir toutes les
conditions générales donc c'est vraiment
un soutien qui est énorme ce qu'ils
proposent un espace de travail qui est
vraiment très agréable et qui permet
d'avoir un espace qui lui vraiment dédié
aux start up qui permet de rester
concentré toute la journée et aussi
devant les autres start up au quotidien
soixante trois start-up ont été créés
depuis 2000 17 17 aujourd'hui en
incubation oui et il y en a également
deux en accélération qui est un nouveau
dispositif que nous avons mis en place
l'année dernière pour les startups qui
sont en phase de déploiement commercial
et donc qui ont besoin d'être encore
plus accompagner pour leur développement
accompagnement financier ressources
humaines
plan de déploiement commercial est donc
là nous en avons deux actuellement eh
bien merci beaucoup alexandra rosetti
merci à vous merci à vous aussi et à
très vite pour un prochain numéro de ski
mag
[Musique]